That daily habit we call eating may seem like a simple fact of life.
But the way we bring food to our plates is changing faster than ever.
Believe it or not, today's youngest adults are preparing more food at home...
...than their parents ever have, thanks to the Internet.
And twenty-four seven food delivery is also driving this explosion of home chefs.
This phenomenon is rapidly changing the rules about how food is marketed and sold.
We're seeing that small market items,...
...products that were once relegated to specialty stores are now moving front and center.
But there's more to it than health concerns.
Millennials have a taste for complex flavors and local charm...
...which has led to a 14-billion-dollar craft beer market.
And artisanal trends don't stop there.
Popular smoked foods like bacon will be even bigger in 2015.
Don't be surprised if smoked flavors show up in vegetables, chocolate or cocktails too.